musique éclatante lumière disco la
chapelle de la commanderie a enfilé son
costume de fête pour le noël décalé de
la commanderie ouverte le mercredi
samedi et dimanche la patinoire
installée pour l'occasion offre aux
enfants et à leurs parents un moment de
partage et de sourire dans une ambiance
animée
sabrina rue du rhône of nations
par ici à points d'avance en tous sens
j'aime bien parce que c'est
s
bliss
c'est semble assez chouette c'est très
bien organisé et réserver par internet
un super accueil l'esat yvette ramon
puisque c'est d'activité on n'a pas
l'habitude de faire on n'a pas de
patinoire dans le secteur ça permet de
les occuper en temps d'hiver c'est
difficile de trouver ses activités
[Musique]
le calendrier des activités va s'étoffer
dans les jours à venir que vous vouliez
écouter de la musique vous exercez en
stop-motion fabriquer des savons ou
encore vous amuser avec un manège
l'heure est à la découverte et à la
convivialité en attendant les fêtes on a
un banias mobile
on a donc l'espace dans lequel on se
trouve qui sera donc qui est un espace
de détente scénographiée par deux
artistes on aura une fanfare qui sera là
samedi et puis donc les ateliers
d'angers parler de création et y aura
notamment un atelier de lanternes ou y
aura une mise à l'eau des lanternes le
marché des créateurs locaux et des
associations solidaires aura lieu quant
à lui le week-end des 11 et 12 décembre